How often and for how long do you spend your time online?
I found among other kinds of addiction, Internet addiction is the hardest to quit.
Many people perhaps agree with me.
I've tried to quit smoking, drinking, and in fact, I did manage to quit.
But I found excessive use of the Internet goes to the point where it disrupts one's life...
...or causes severe stress on family, friends or work environment.
Let's face the reality,...
...how long can you go without the Internet or your personal computer?
Oh, I can't imagine myself spending my day without sitting in front of my laptop.
Like you said, I also think it is one addiction that most people find difficult to quit.
But for most women, I guess shopping would also be difficult to quit.
Well, since there is an escalating number of metrosexuals,...
...men also might agree with my opinion.
Anyways, there even is a word "shopaholic", which means someone who is addicted to shopping.
When I get depressed, I go shopping,...
...and when I'm happy, I also go shopping!
When I get really stressed, I go out and shop, and I feel much better.
It seems like shopping is the hardest addiction for me.
It's tough, but I will seek another activity or hobby to replace those addictions so I can quit.